Let's go back to the experiment.
We know he used an inclined plane to roll balls for the purpose of slowing down the motion.
We know he used a water clock to measure time. This water clock couldn't measure seconds.
He didn't know that the time this clock measured
was proportion of the amount of water collected in this collecting device,
so he collected this much water in your first experiment
and twice as much as water in your second experiment.
The second experiment took twice this long. So how they did do the actual experiment?
First, you'll roll the ball for 1 unit of time,
and a unit here is to find some specified amount of water.
You'll let the ball roll and then measure the distance.
So maybe after 1 unit of time, the ball had gone from here to here.
So how did Galileo do his experiment?
Well, you'll have the ball to roll for 1 unit of time or unit of time with a specified amount of water,
and you'll measure the distance.
This distance you would call 1 unit of distance let say.
So if the ball rolled from here to here in 1 unit of time, this became 1 unit of distance.
Notice that Galileo wasn't really concerned
whether these units were seconds or minutes or meters or inches.
He was looking for proportions and improportions.  These units always cancel out.
So, Galileo really didn't care about these things.
After he did that for 1 unit of time, he would allow the ball to roll for 2  units of time
and then measure the distance and again for 3 and 4 and so on.
He'll keep doing this for 3 units of time, 4, 5, and so on,
and when he was done, he would repeat the entire experiment many many times,
because more data means you can reduce your error, and we'll talk about that now.